Tomorrow's your day to die.
What's your last meal?
Filthy, dirty, buttery potatoes,
with a beautiful Sauvignon Blanc
from the Marlborough region of New Zealand,
and old school prawn cocktail.
And you?
A really beautiful cut in half avocado
with fresh vine ripe tomatoes and a little bit of mozzerella,
and a really good Spaghetti Bolognese.
How did Rebecca come into your life?
I got the pilot sent through
in a kind of secret squirrel type way.
One of those, like weird, where you can’t...
You can see this, but you can't see this.
On one device, yeah.
You know it exists, but you don't.
Mhm.
And um, yeah, I wasn't told what it was for,
who it was for, who'd created it.
Nothing.
But that actually afforded me the luxury
to just go, oh who is this woman
at face value.
That's the first time, I think ever
because it was so secret squirrel,
do you have a, is there a different
expression in America for that?
Like secret badger or something?
Um, it's just like top secret, right?
It’s almost like…
So not secret squirrel.
Well no but I love that, you know.
Um, so then I just learned, learned all the sides
and went into town to a casting,
and I don't know about you,
but I just, I, I go (gibberish)
leave what you think is the best
you can do on camera
and I always come out and tear it up.
Me too 'cause also you want to leave it
in the room when it's that top secret.
Yeah, yeah.
You’re like, don’t give me the responsibility!
It can't be in my recycling, oh my god.
Because if that gets out...
With my name on it!
Exactly.
I'd kind of forgotten about it.
and went back to being Mama,
picking my girl up from school.
And then the day it, they said no you’ve got it,
I had to go and pick my daughter up from school,
walk through the very, very normal playground
and not go, oh my god my life just changed!
If your house went up in flames,
what would be the things you would grab?
It would be my girl, over my shoulder
and I'm good to go.
You've known Jason for ages, haven't you?
I knew him for a little while yeah, beforehand
and I'd been working in Europe for about six months.
Got back to LA,
turned thirty which was epic,
don't tell anyone.
That is quite a long time ago for me.
Don't tell anyone.
Twenty-eight forever.
But I got a text from Jason
being like, "Yo yo, uh, Jason here."
"Got your number."
"and, uh just want to chat to you about something."
to which I thought, oh he thinks I’m someone else.
Oh no.
I love your faith in yourself.
So, so yeah, well I’m working on that.
But so then he, I was like
“Hey, what can I do for you?”
and he said well I actually have this pilot
that I would love you to read if you have a moment
or if you would be interested.
It’s something that I am reaching out to you personally
about because it means a lot to me.
And so, I was like, are you kidding me?
Quietly thinking, what if it’s not meant for me,
like this is a disaster.
So I did read it
and I just thought it was such an unusual pilot.
I hadn't read anything like it
'cause it made you laugh and also made you
feel really emotional from the get-go,
You know?
And, so then I called him
and when he said, "Hey Juno!"
I was like aah.
There has been no confusion.
It was for me!
You and I come from two such
totally different comfort zones
You are nervous doing comedy,
which nobody would believe on camera,
and I come from...
The world of theater.
Big sell was he did talk to me
about this relationship between the two of us.
Which was one that first and foremost
he was really passionate about
and really cared about these two women
helping each other in ways
they didn’t know were even possible.
So you knew about
I didn’t know anything about this relationship.
I knew there was going to be
this relationship that blossomed.
And I didn’t know the specifics of it.
Like when I read that script
that where it immediately is about
about you naked on a yacht
and that’s so specific and I push you,
push you and push you to see it because
I’m like come on, you were dying to show someone.
Yeah.
And that moment of you kind of being like oh,
I actually should be proud of
my beauty as a woman.
and it’s special where it is
on this couch right here, isn’t it?
Like Rebecca in her formality.
Even the shape of what that scene looked like.
And it’s a real turning point.
And I think it’s the first time in a while
that Rebecca has heard a compliment
from a female that she’s believed
I felt in that moment.
Because I’m not sure either of
these women have experienced
love and friendship like you say
from another female
and very much of different generations.
It feels like they are kind of soul mates,
but they didn’t know that until
episodes start progressing and
by the end of season one I truly believe that.
And then there’s the twist that happens
at the end that I know we’ve talked about.
Being able to call each other out.
Being accountable.
Yeah.
But it’s scary isn’t it and I think like
as two women sitting here talking
about these characters,
we can relate to them on such deep levels.
I know you can.
Your, your insight into Rebecca as a woman
is something that I watch as
we've done press together about it.
And learning about how much
she meant to you in a
deep, deep way that makes you have such
understanding of her which is why
she is such an extraordinary character in this.
When you first started playing Rebecca,
do you feel they made her more
in tune with Hannah?
Yeah, I think I felt a shift around the...
Oh my god, the scene at the gala
outside with you and Jason.
Yes.
That was probably more personal than anything?
Yeah, yeah it was.
Yeah, because I think by then,
Yeah.
I think by then, Jason, I mean he was lit...
you know what he’s like fiddling
around with scripts and writing up
up against a wall with Brett.
SNL world.
I mean, yeah.
Can learn lines like that.
Yeah, I balked at that.
I was like oh my god you can’t
give me something like 10 minutes
before we’re gonna be on camera
and he still did because he knew
that I was limiting myself.
And I was just like this is getting ridiculous
how close to my life this has been.
Our girlfriends are the most important people.
Oh my god, yeah.
They ground us, they save our lives,
and hopefully we do the same for them.
Undoubtedly.
Just the grace and ease of which you are a mother,
you are an extraordinary actress,
and you are a woman in a way that I,
I’m excited to grow up and be a woman because of it
I think it’s a very inspirational package.
No one could have played
this character Rebecca better.
You know that,
you know that 'cause you understand it all.
You know I am horrendous with compliments.
But I feel the same about you,
and it’s, and I can’t believe my luck
that you were even back for season two.
I thought she’s so big-time she’ll be like off.
Oh come on.
Suddenly go, I’ll suddenly hear
Juno’s not coming back to this.
No no no, because she’s doing this giant
thing somewhere in outer Mongolia.
She saved my mental health.
I wouldn’t want to miss this for the world.
This whole cast, this crew, like everybody,
this character is like.
Sure, I love the darkness, you know I do.
But I also, when we sit here, I get stopped
in a grocery store with someone going like
“Hey, did I go to school with you?"
"Oh no, I’ve just seen your boobs in a movie."
And you're like over Cheerios in the
Trader Joe’s or something, it’s like um…
I know, but I have told you before you
have to celebrate the fact that people
say that because they are magnificent.
Great.
All of it is.
I mean, touché. Touché.
But I think like the fact that we get to
do it one more time, is like thank God.
I was literally just about to say
what does that make you feel
about wrapping on season two?
Proud, but also really nervous
because you’re just like,
you just want to make people proud.
Now that we know about the success of season one,
you just hope that people also respond to it
in a way that they love our character journeys
and still connect with them in a way
that they did with season one
even if they bring different emotions
and new journeys and all that.
Yeah, I think season two is quite different
So do I.
In terms of really getting into the dirt.
Yeah, exactly the human side of it
which we all bottle up.
that we don’t necessarily talk about.
I think they should have a jelly fight
in season three and really go for it.
Or a pillow fight,
in a hotel room.
Or a bath.
I just keep pushing.
Our extraordinary female writers
do us such a great service.
Yeah.
You know, and one storyline in particular
that I have this year, I even spoke to Jason about it
and I was like who’s mainly responsible for this
and he said well they are and they are.
And I was like I need to go give them a squeeze
and go come on the girls!
'cause it’s just blindsided me
and I love that they have literally gone
go on, do that that gets you
out of your comfort zone.
Yeah, don’t be shy. They’re very brave.
Big time.
And the most important female that’s joined us
this year is magnificent Sarah Niles.
Sarah Niles!
And I would like to genuinely put
in a bit of a complaint, in fact I did to Jason.
I was like I would’ve liked to
have more to do with Sarah.
With her.
Because yes, the stuff we did in here
with Sarah I was like oh oh oh oh oh oh oh!
The first read through that we had on Zoom
and she started reading that character
of a therapist, sports therapist and I was like...
She brought a very chilled out,
effortless power and is a brilliant foil
to where yours and my characters are.
But also has an arc that,
audiences be excited because again,
as per usual with Ted Lasso,
don’t judge a book by its cover.
Yeah.
Maybe this time next year we’ll be able
to have her on the couch too.
Yes.
I will never forget that moment where somebody
said to us “this is a show I want to show my daughter"
"because of the relationship you two have created.”
And it really took the wind out of us both, didn’t it?
That’s the highest compliment we could get.